j'ai représenté montréal avec panache je
crois que c'est ce que mourir le mérite
alors vous venez de l'entendre charles
lapointe l'ancien pdg de tourisme
montréal considère avoir bien fait son
travail
il devait justifier aujourd'hui
certaines dépenses dont on a beaucoup
parlé en commission parlementaire david
gentilles et charles lapointe se défend
d'avoir dépensé sans compter
dans un premier temps il admet qu'il
n'aurait pas dû réclamer à l'impôt des
dépenses qui dans les fêtes lui avaient
été remboursées par tourisme montréal
pour le reste par exemple quant à ses
dépenses de restaurant des montants
impressionnants trente neuf mille
dollars en deux ans charles lapointe
nous dit en substance écouter lorsque
l'on reçoit des étrangers des
journalistes on ne peut pas les invités
dans des snacks bars ça coûte de
l'argent vendre montréal on écoute là
dessus l'ancien pdg de tourisme montréal
j'ai fait une utilisation judicieuse des
deniers publics et privés qui était à ma
disposition et les résultats après vingt
quatre ans une croissance qui a duré
pendant deux décennies
et si vous avez lu la presse de samedi
2013 est une très bonne année pour le
tourisme montréalais je crois que les
résultats battent en ce sens sur la
faune patricia un malentendu c'est que
d'un côté tourisme montréal dit on n'a
pas de comptes à rendre
on est une organisation privée pourquoi
mène-t-il cet argumentaire c'est qu'ils
disent que 80% de leurs revenus
étant issu d'une taxe qui est perçue
surtout auprès de touristes étrangers
ils sont malgré leur statut d'organisme
sans but lucratif une organisation
privée qui n'a de compte à rendre à
personne
là dessus évidemment les parlementaires
n'étaient pas d'accord mais c'est un peu
le dilemme que devra trancher
le ministre ou clarifier le ministre
pascal bérubé dans les semaines et les
mois à venir mais dites-moi david en
conclusion les dépenses il avait quand
même demander des remboursements pour
une allocation voiture alors qu'il avait
un chauffeur c'est ce qu'il
il a fait son mea culpa lors il a dit là
dessus je me suis trompé
même chose pour les dons de charité mais
pour le reste
monsieur charles lapointe n'était pas
repentant merci david hackett concours à
bonn soir